uh india has abstained on a vote in the
security council uh it has failed to
explicitly condemn the invasion of
ukraine well what did the prime minister
say about it on the plane when we came
over
he said that he uh would address some of
these issues with prime minister modi
who he will meet in new delhi tomorrow
but he said
that the uk had to do this with india as
equal partners he said that he had to
recognize the historic relationship
between india
and russia and also recognize uh the
relationship historically between the uk
and india the uk being
a former colonial power perhaps the
indian government would not particularly
appreciate the uk government telling
them how to run their foreign policy so
it is a sensitive subject but the prime
minister was clear that he would
certainly ask prime minister
modi or talk to him at least about the
possibility of reducing india's
dependence on russian
military equipment and will of course
raise the matters of ukraine but in
quite a delicate way the second big
thing he wants to do here is that trade
deal both countries want to get that
done they hope to nail it down by the
end of the year both prime ministers
with an eye on the 2024 elections they
have respectively but it will be tough
uh on the uk's part they want to sell
more alcoholic spirits more cars and car
parts to india and india's part they
would probably like more visas now the
prime minister opened the door to that
on the plane saying that the uk needed
hundreds of thousands more workers but
that any immigration plan had to be
controlled so watch this space see what
they have to say on that i think we're
going to be hearing from the prime
minister quite a bit today as he tries
to keep the focus very much on what he's
doing in india and very much away from
what's going on back home